well that's what sucks the iron out of
the nope again he doesn't want to play
music at all yeah I just want to use the
magnet in the back of the speaker and
suck the iron out of the sand what is
the purpose of the magnet again on those
subs I don't know but they have magnets
yeah to suck out the iron out of sand
[Music]
taken away in class [__] yeah everything
like what a [__] speaker a speaker
why did you have a speaker playing in
classroom in fourth grade did you guys
do the theme where like everyone brought
like magnets out to [__] with the
sandbox and you can collect all those
yeah black dust right yeah everyone had
a little magnet and then most people
will start bringing bigger magnets like
they got from the fabric store because
you know you like your needles do not
lose your needles right now this story
so they'll have like big ones right yeah
and then for me I'm like man [__] you
guys you guys don't know [__] I know
where the biggest magnet is and it's the
back of my dad's uh subwoofer in his
home theater oh yeah I drilled I on drug
it was like a 12 inch sub I [__] uh
dumped all my back my books out of my
backpack I stuffed it in there and then
the whole time in class I had it like
between my legs and I was like you
[__] just waiting
and I didn't even make it to the [__]
uh sound box the teacher's like what is
that and then she took it away dude we
needed a 12 inch like circular 12 inch
sub where the magnets like this big in
the back we need to satisfy 4th grade
Bart we need to get a [__] speaker
from like a thrift shop right from that
era
find one that's like this big and we
need to go to the beat go to sound yep
let's go just go and just yeah go to are
we sure we don't want to just cut the
speaker out and just get a magnet it has
to be that no we have to fulfill his
original Destiny it's gonna be a Kenwood
one a Ken we gotta bring a generator to
have electricity to plug it into oh wait
the magnet doesn't work without it no
the magnet's already on there oh that's
the that's what powers it well that's
what sucks the iron out of the nope
again he doesn't want to play music at
all yeah I just want to use the magnet
in the back of the speaker and suck the
iron out of the sand oh what is the
purpose of the magnet again on those
subs I don't know but they have magnets
yeah to suck out the iron out of sand
how did you build a magnet there yeah I
think that was probably one of those
days like peeking behind what I'm not
supposed to be and then I was like oh
there's a big manic near here so the
reason I'm asking is when you got that
thing taken away did you try to get it
back or anything would you just wait
till no try to get it back and get my
ass whooped because my [__] dad finds
out that I don't I don't have the
speaker so she didn't tell your parent
parents or anything no she gave it back
to you at the end of the day no she just
kept it and like the whole year I just
stared the whole year at the bottom of
Verdes I'm trying to like scheme ways to
steal it back I wonder how you're if
your dad ever wanted to listen to
Chinese Opera or some [__] and he's like
man this speak of [__] he did find out
he did open the because you know it's
like a screen so he pulled the screen
now he's like where's my speaker who am
I speaking of he's the big hole
of course I got my ass with anyways
speaking of getting your ass whooped
there's a teenager in Florida he's 17
years old he uh got his Nintendo switch
taken away during class because you're
not supposed to have a freaking Nintendo
switch Yeah in class
um and this is what he had to say about
it oh
I've seen this video oh I haven't
whoa [__] that's his teacher whoa that's
a big boy that's a big boy oh my God
she's like tapping him please stop oh oh
my God bro whoa whoa for taking away his
switch
that's a big ass kid bro yo people
aren't even stopping him people are like
right yeah they're not ready for that yo
that boy is bigger than all the adults
there yo did he go yo he's still kicking
her and there's like they gotta get
there faster is she knocked out yeah
yeah she got beaten unconscious oh my
God she was knocked out from the push
holy pretty crazy how big is that kid is
that like a he's 270 pounds six six oh
[__] that's what I was saying that's not
a child that's a big ass [__] kid I
mean is that a Samoan baby no wonder she
was tapping him on the shoulder
as [__] yeah he's a big kid man
holy crap but yeah that's he basically
almost killed her yeah how old is this
kid 17. 17 duffel is probably gonna get
tried it as a dollar or something damn
dude we're gonna be in the movie The
Blind Side that's how [__] big he is
oh yeah
it's like something 's for like [__] for
the wild he's like starting Valley
you know what's crazy too is like
depending on where you're looking you'll
hear a lot of people kind of on his side
yo take it from the first place you're a
beach or like people saying like oh that
is clearly a person that was not like
developmentally nurtured correctly so
he's acting out based on things that
were done to him yeah that's that's true
depending on where you look that's also
true but also you can't do you also
think the teacher was like pretty messed
up and it just kept building up until he
was like Snapped well that still doesn't
justify violence right so you can still
charge someone for a crime that they
commit and also have understanding and
empathy of how they got there totally
but also you still gotta [__] charge
them for what they did yeah you can't
take a size this is also what's behind
the California like Catch and Release
policy where like oh he's only robbing
houses because you guys know what he's
been going through and then so they they
rob I mean they incarcerate them for
literally a day and then they're
released again he's been robbing houses
because he has social anxiety yeah like
get them but that's the same kind of um
it's crazy because like do we allow
child predators to go on doing what they
do because most of them were actually
victims of the said crime yeah three R
Kelly they should free your kids that's
the same [__] but no we don't give them
a pass we we don't [__] let them do
that his brother yeah so like graped
all right
let me write make sure I put it out Bart
said great great job that's a good
marker for him oh speaking of grapes I
have grapes oh yeah dude wash them you
know what I don't think it's Justified
like I still don't think it's right that
he did it but I also see why he did it
because the stardew valley is such a
good game see why people like that would
like you know get angry at that stuff
because it's like if gaming is all you
have to like kind of like pacify
whatever you go through yeah but you're
not even supposed to have that at school
exactly School exactly because we don't
know what's wrong with him or his family
situation but I I don't think it's right
that he beat her up but I also almost
kill her I mean he's he's clearly like
one you know those kids you guys know
those kids like they just snap they're
just something's wrong I mean he lives
in a group home so it's already a sign
that he's probably going through some
weird [__] but also like it says that
while he was being processed uh he kept
asking the deputy when he was going to
be released and he started kicking the
desk and became violent when they
weren't answering him so it's like he
has this thing like ongoing because you
know to me this reminds me of like
um
like you know like uh like a like a
violent Pit Bull or whatever right they
look at Pit Bulls that have like like
they bite people or whatever yeah and
it's not the dog's fault
it was it was maybe trained to be a
fighting dog it was raised in a [__]
up situation so it's like well but at
the same time that that dog is a threat
yeah because it's like yeah it's not the
doggy's fault I feel bad for the doggy
but you can't also take this dog to the
dog park and play with other doggies
because they'll start [__] killing
and biting other dogs right so it's like
it's the same situation where like yeah
you can you can see how it all ended up
but then he needs to be dealt with in a
special case yeah it should you know
said kid
be put in a situation where he's with
all these sheep and he's a wolf yeah
right so like maybe there needs to be a
a a a a place where they're uh
like
educated into getting back into society
and operating that way because like for
example if you're
from the hood right and then you're and
then your whole like way of survival is
if someone has like a small tendency to
bully you then you need to destroy that
[__] because you're gonna get
bullied right so if this is your
mentality and then all of a sudden you
go to this peaceful little Asian
neighborhood all of a sudden and then
you're used to operating that way and
then the kid just looks at you and
you're like oh [__] this reminds me of
like when I was back in my old
neighborhood and you [__] them up the
the same rules do not apply so it's kind
of like that like I don't know if I'm
explaining it right well it's clear this
kid needs some love and he needs some
extra care
but letting him go after he did that to
somebody is not the right answer like
Joe said you totally empathize for a
situation but what he did to that woman
that was a wrong to her is all so there
was a boundary there's a kid like this
at this uh tutoring Academy I should I
used to tutor at in San Marino
and he was this kid that like all the
teachers were scared of so like he he's
part of like the um
like after school pickup service where
like that they have a service where they
just go and pick up like all the kids
from the junior highs and stuff in high
school and they'll just bring them to
this after school academy he goes
straight to a desk and just puts his
hand down and I hit his head down and
all the teachers are scared of him
because if you go and try to wake him up
like hey you should do some work he just
gets up and just starts swinging and
he's big he's like uh David sized when
he's like 15. okay so like the uh owner
she was like I can't just have him just
be here like this
um but I also don't know what to do so
she actually asked me to see if I can
help him in any way and So like
um what I started to do was I was like
you know what just drop them off at his
house and I'll start at his house I
don't want to be in an environment where
like there's no kids that are kind of
like in a wrong state of mind if they
feel like they need to like go crazy
they will yeah like especially if they
feel like they're getting challenged so
he just started with like the first week
I just showed up at his house and I try
to like not even get him to do because
uh I was actually hired to help him get
in shape a little bit more
um and I was like I'm not even gonna
start with with that because I have to
build rapport they just started with me
coming over with like some snacks first
and then just chilling in the house and
after like a week of just being in the
house and he felt like okay this this
teacher isn't like the other teachers
the second week on the mission school
for a walk and we started going for a
walk and then the third week I was like
Hey like do you do you like hurting
people and he was like you kind of see
this glimmer in his eye he's like
what the
[__] and then I found out he was like a
parachute kid his dad's doing business
in China it's just him he's just angry
as [__] all the time yeah it took a lot
of time but of course there were San
Marino parents so they could afford to
flood this Academy full of money too
right like don't kick him out don't like
to help keep supporting that but it was
it was like a very similar situation
because all the other like teachers were
really smart teachers and they're not
used to they're used to like oh my son's
a freshman but he does calculus and
they're used to teaching those kids so
when you have a kid that's just like
like yeah and if you go like this he
just gets up and just starts swinging
doesn't matter if it's a guy or girl
everyone was [__] scared God damn
dude what happened to him how did he
turn out I don't know uh JK was doing
well so I quit my job
hopefully he watches we're thinking
about you
[Music]